let me ask you about your life I look at
your life your uncle is the president of
the United States Camelot we all know so
much about the presidency of your uncle
the short presidency of your uncle and
your father the Attorney General at the
time uh and then your father makes a run
for president and like his brother he
was assassinated
you have suggested that you believe
there was a conspiracy within our
government intelligence agencies more
specifically you mentioned the CIA and
that you even believe yourself today
because of your last name I'm assuming
that your life could be in jeopardy
why do you believe that they were
involved in the assassination of both
your your dad and your uncle and maybe
yet you may be a Target well I haven't
said that I may be a target people have
asked me if I I mean there's always for
anybody who runs for president anybody
who is on on Fox is a target but go
ahead
you know I mean I I think I've taken a
lot worse risks in my life than running
for president so I I'm uh but it's also
got to be hard you lost your uncle you
lost your father I mean that's horrible
yeah but what are you saying are you no
so why do you think that our government
could be involved it wasn't when
the Warren Commission obviously which
was run by Alan Dulles who was the head
of the CIA who my uncle fired
found that it was a loan shooter which
was Lee Harvey Oswald
but when Congress a congressional
committee reinvestigated between 1977
and 1979 the house select assassinations
committee
They concluded and they saw a lot more
documentation and had a lot more
witnesses and the Warren Commission ever
saw
They concluded that my uncle was killed
by a conspiracy
and most of the people for example
Richard Schweitzer who was the first the
head of the committee
publicly said uh JFK John the president
United States was convinced the CIA was
involved in the murder of the president
United States and that's quotation
most of the people on that committee at
that time believed it was the CIA that
it was believed certain people in the
CIA was you were seven at the time seven
or eight I was I was 10 when my uncle
was killed when I was 14 when my father
was killed
oh
um you know the and today there's
overwhelming evidence I mean in fact one
of the it was it was something to
release all of the files on it and let
it let be transparent let us see the
yeah
well that's a good question there's
still you know the law requires there
there's a law that requires that all the
records of John Kennedy's assassination
be released to the public
10 years ago so they're still holding 5
000 documents President Biden promised
when he was elected that he was going to
release those documents president Trump
promised that he would
but the CIA doesn't want them to and so
the question that I think Americans have
a right to ask including members of you
know my father and uncle's family is
why not what is it that you don't want
to see 60 years later
and by the way go wow
you know the last
the last drawing the last tranche of
documents released
um had documentation in there that
finally got even the New York Times in
mid
at Lee Harvey Oswald was a CIA asset and
he was working for the CIA so I mean
America if the Warren Commission had
known that back in in you know 1964
they would have had a very different
time and the house assassinations
committee never knew that that was
released some you know we've known that
we've had documentation that known that
at least a decade
but some of that documentation became
overwhelming in this last raunch and
finally the mainstream media
acknowledged that yeah he had this
relationship with the CIA going back to
1957 or 1958. hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else